[Musica]
il mondo del lavoro sta cambiando
profondamente sotto la spinta di forze
che vanno ben oltre i confini nazionali
forse come il progresso tecnologico la
globalizzazione che essendo molto più
grandi di noi ci fanno sentire come in
balia delle onde come incapaci di
governare i processi di trasformazione
di cui siamo parte invece il messaggio
che cercherò di lasciarvi oggi è che la
trasformazione del mondo del lavoro si
può e si deve governare attraverso
politiche economiche coraggiose che più
di ogni altra cosa a puntino a ridurre
le disuguaglianze che stanno aumentando
nel mercato del lavoro e che rischiano
di destabilizzare la nostra società
cominciamo dalla premessa che il mondo
effettivamente è composto di processi
produttivi che sono diventati sempre più
tecnologicamente avanzati e sempre più
integrati a livello globale per darvi un
esempio l'iphone che sicuramente alcuni
di voi avranno in tasca in questa sala
si compone di parti che arrivano da
oltre 43 paesi diversi
l'aereo che mi ha portato qui oggi viene
assemblato con componenti che vengono
prodotti da mille aziende diverse
in più di 30 paesi
quindi come capita benissimo la
globalizzazione il processo tecnologico
stanno trasformando il modo in cui
produciamo il modo in cui lavoriamo e
questo crea delle preoccupazioni crea
delle preoccupazioni perché le aziende
possono vedere fette di mercato
volatilizzarsi con l'arrivo di un'app
perché i lavoratori pensano di trovarsi
in difficoltà in ritardo rispetto alla
tecnologia e rispetto ai rischi che il
mondo del lavoro pone sono due le
preoccupazioni che aleggiano
principalmente nella mente dei
lavoratori la prima stanno arrivando i
robot e ci ruberanno il lavoro la
seconda i nostri lavori stanno
semplicemente andando verso posti del
mondo dove la manodopera costa meno
comunque
la si voglia analizzare la questione
quindi qualunque delle due forze
pensiamo sia la più importante secondo
me c'è una domanda fondamentale che
occorre porre perché c'è nella mente
delle persone a causa di questi trend è
effettivamente vero che dobbiamo
preoccuparci di un aumento della
disoccupazione di una riduzione del
lavoro nel futuro perché magari le
macchine faranno tutto
la risposta secondo noi è no e no perché
in realtà è vero le macchine stanno
avanzando qui vi mostro la produzione di
robot per uso industriale che sta
aumentando tantissimo ma allo stesso
tempo durante questo periodo di
esplosione tecnologica e avanzato anche
il tasso di impiego incredibilmente
nonostante i robot distruggessero lavoro
nell'insieme l'impiego è aumentato da
vent'anni fa a prima della crisi a oggi
nella maggior parte dei paesi non tutti
ma il trend sicuramente non è negativo
come possibile beh innanzitutto sfatiamo
un mito è possibile perché la tecnologia
non distrugge soltanto lavoro
l'automazione non distrugge soltanto
lavoro anzi ne crea più di quanto ne
distrugga come lo fa senza almente
rendendoci più produttivi permettendoci
di aver bisogno di meno tempo per
produrre le stesse risorse e quindi
liberando tempo e ricchezza che possiamo
dedicare a nuove attività generando
nuovo lavoro cosa fa invece la
globalizzazione crea degli squilibri
crea delle difficoltà e ci arriveremo ma
allo stesso tempo crea lavoro in italia
il 35 per cento dei lavori nel settore
privato sono lavori che dipendono
direttamente dalla domanda estera è una
cifra enorme che vi fa riflettere in un
periodo in cui sentiamo parlare di
guerre commerciali di dazi di barriere e
così via
quindi con questa premessa ci viene da
chiederci allora qual è il problema
perché tanta preoccupazione se la
globalizzazione e la tecnologia
aumentano più di distruggere il lavoro
più di ridurre il lavoro è il problema è
che non tutti nell'economia beneficiano
allo stesso modo dal cambiamento
tecnologico e dai benefici della
globalizzazione
e vero in totale i lavori aumentano però
alcuni sicuramente vengono distrutti
secondo l'ocse e il 14 per cento dei
lavori la cifra che indica quanti lavori
siano a rischio di essere automatizzati
nella prossima decade o due
il punto è che questi lavori non sono
equamente distribuiti nella popolazione
sono le fasce più deboli i lavoratori
con con competenze inferiori quelli che
tipicamente si trovano più svantaggiati
e quindi il punto fondamentale della
questione e preoccuparsi dell'aumento
delle disparità e delle disuguaglianze
che creano esattamente il tipo di
tensioni che vediamo ogni giorno nella
nostra società
tensioni tra chi guadagna e tensioni tra
chi perde tensioni tra chi beneficia
attenzioni e tra chi beneficia meno dei
cambiamenti in corso occorre dire
un'altra cosa
questo non è una questa non è una storia
nuova la tecnologia sempre trasformato
il mondo del lavoro
tanti lavori sono spariti in passato
però oggi siamo nella posizione di poter
aiutare quelli che da queste
trasformazioni si trovano più
svantaggiati perché abbiamo i mezzi e
perché abbiamo imparato di più su come
farlo quindi la domanda fondamentale che
occorre porre e dare una risposta
assolutamente affermativa è occorre
intervenire sul mercato del lavoro per
ridurre queste disuguaglianze e la
risposta è assolutamente sì direi
ne va della stabilità della nostra
società come
ci sono una serie di aree di politica
economica che potremo toccare troppe per
il tempo a disposizione
concentriamoci su quelle che ci
preoccupano di più il primo argomento è
quello della formazione qui parliamo di
formazione per adulti non scuola voglio
darvi qualche cifra su cosa fa e come
funziona il sistema di formazione per
adulti per quelli che sono già nel
mercato del lavoro e magari per via di
un cambiamento tecnologico hanno bisogno
di riqualificarsi e in un mondo in cui
la tecnologia è sempre più veloce o può
essere sempre più veloce diventa sempre
più importante avere strumenti del
genere
ebbene i sistemi di formazione che
abbiamo oggi fanno esattamente il
contrario di quello che dovrebbero fare
danno più formazione ai lavoratori che
hanno già più competenze e danno meno
formazione ai lavoratori che si trovano
di fronte un rischio di automazione
maggiore ovvero i lavoratori con
competenze inferiori che avrebbero più
bisogno di formazione quelli che si
trovano più facilmente a fronteggiare il
rischio dell'automazione di perdere di
lavoro perché arriva una macchina ed in
piazza ricevono meno formazione non più
di quelli che hanno rischi inferiori la
secondaria che ci preoccupa in un mondo
in cui il lavoro diventa sempre più
precario e l'abbiamo visto perché
abbiamo dati che ci mostrano che la
stabilità dei lavori sta diminuendo e il
sistema della previdenza sociale che non
è preparato ad aiutare le persone delle
transizioni del mercato del lavoro nei
paesi ocse due lavoratori su tre non
ricevono sussidi di disoccupazione
quando ne hanno bisogno
infine in un mondo in cui aziende sempre
più grandi hanno potere di mercato
sempre maggiore il potere negoziale dei
lavoratori diminuisce e questo tra le
altre cose è legato a una diminuzione
dei tassi di sindacalizzazione più o
meno ovunque
potremmo toccare tante altre aree di
interesse ma ovviamente non c'è nel
tempo quello però il messaggio con cui
vorrei concludere e che
come dicevo all'inizio il futuro è nelle
nostre mani nel senso che non siamo in
una su una nave in balia delle onde che
non si può guidare in alcun modo e
attraverso politiche coraggiose possiamo
effettivamente puntare a un mondo che
sia più equo e più giusto come lo
facciamo lo facciamo con politiche di
lungo periodo che siano mirate a ridurre
le disuguaglianze nel lungo periodo e
non soltanto a vincere le prossime
elezioni
lo facciamo avendo il coraggio di
ammettere che le riforme che abbiamo
discusso oggi sono risorse riforme che
hanno bisogno di risorse non si fanno
gratis e queste risorse vanno trovate
con una fiscalità più equa e più
efficace e riducendo gli sprechi occorre
anche rendersi conto che per soluzioni
per problemi globali come quelli che
abbiamo discusso oggi servono soluzioni
globali e pensare di fare da soli da
staterelli singoli in un mondo in cui le
forze in gioco sono così forti e futile
anacronistico forse addirittura
pericoloso e infine conclude rai dicendo
che diminuire le disuguaglianze
attraverso le politiche che abbiamo
discusso brevemente oggi e attraverso
anche altri strumenti non vuol dire
soltanto aiutare chi sta peggio
vuol dire aiutarci tutti perché una
società più divisa una società più
conflittuale una società che per via di
queste divisioni tende anche
potenzialmente verso gli estremismi è
una società economicamente più debole e
anche probabilmente una società più
infelice per tutti
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]